now the coronavirus pandemic has now
claimed five million lives nearly two
years after the first outbreak in the
chinese city of wuhan kovid 19 remains a
leading cause of death around the world
the united states has the highest
official toll with more than 700 000
recorded deaths and less than 60 percent
of the population fully vaccinated
brazil has also been hit heavily losing
more than 600 000 lives and india's
second wave ruined the country's hopes
of avoiding the worst the official death
toll there stands at just over 450 000
but many researchers estimate the real
number is at least a million
a family broken apart by covet 19. james
mawangi watches as his uncle is lowered
into the ground just days after he
buried his father and grandmother
we are traumatized
because it's not so easy some people you
are with them tweets ago they had no
issue
then all of a sudden
in a span of less than 10 days they're
all gone
this funeral is in kenya but grief has
touched every corner of the globe
in under two years the virus has cut
short the lives of five million people
from mass grave sites in brazil to
overfilled hospitals in the uk
the world has learned a new meaning of
loss since the pandemic began in early
2020
the world's wealthiest were not spared
the u.s has the highest official death
toll of any country
tate as i and his pregnant wife turned
down the vaccine
and then she fell ill
it says things got worse and worse
i started really worrying and worried
about the baby
and then
at some point you know the baby just
didn't make it she was too low on oxygen
no country has suffered a wave of covet
19 as swift and deadly as india's by the
time its second wave subsided the
official death toll had reached 400 000
but most rigorous studies estimate it
was at least twice as much
42 year old school teacher cavender
singh was one of the victims
beloved by his community his funeral
brought together friends and family he
was one of many bid farewell at this
booked out crematorium
what can we do yes we're angry but what
can we do we don't know how many people
are suffering like him even in my own
village and nearby villages there are
people like him in their 40s who are
teachers who have died in my village six
or seven people have active infections
while the virus continues to spread
around the globe vaccines as well as new
treatments have begun to help slow the
death rate
it's now a matter of getting these
life-saving innovations to as many
people as possible
well germany is also seeing a sharp
increase in new coronavirus cases
numbers are up from just under 500 new
infections a day in mid-july to more
than 27 000 new cases and one day at the
end of last week
concerns over a possible a fourth wave
of health officials pushing for a rapid
rollout of booster shots before winter
but what's also worrying is the number
of fully vaccinated people who are
amongst the new cases
dw's tessa valtter spoke with a doctor
who became a patient
even simple things are still difficult
for leo hulsburma two weeks after her
covert 19 infection the 30 year old
still struggles to get back to her old
life
normally i go running every other day
and do a lot of other sports and
exercise but i put all that on hold for
now simply because i notice my breathing
is still a bit tight when i climb stairs
i notice i have to do it slowly i have
to catch my breath a lot and i have to
take breaks
leoba still tries to get more rest than
usual
finding her way back into her job as a
surgeon is difficult she contracted
covet 19 despite being fully vaccinated
for over two weeks she was sick at home
i did not expect to have such a severe
illness i thought someone like me at 30
with no pre-existing conditions would
just lie in bed for two or three days
and relax the rest of the time in
quarantine but it was definitely not
like that for me i was very very sick
for two weeks
more and more breakthrough infections
are being reported in germany
among around 55 million fully vaccinated
people around 118 000 had a breakthrough
infection
this number is also visible in intensive
care units
according to current figures around 10
percent of people in icus between 18 and
59 are fully vaccinated it is even 30
for over 60 year olds
see
however that doesn't mean that
vaccination doesn't work if you look at
the number of breakthrough infections
you see that they still represent the
minority although the number of
vaccinated people is much higher
from this ratio alone you see that a
vaccination still protects really well
leo's vaccination was over seven months
ago
which could be the reason for her
infection
despite her experience she would get
vaccinated again
i have in no way lost faith in
vaccination i'll definitely continue to
be vaccinated against all infectious
diseases i believe the course of my
disease would have been much more
serious without being vaccinated and it
protects you from dying of infectious
diseases or from suffering a severe bout
even
now takes everything step by step
and she's hopeful that she'll fully
recover soon
well dr tina rudolph is not only a
medical doctor but also a member of the
german parliament for the social
democrats so welcome to dw doctor
how much of a risk are these
breakthrough coveted infections
yes this was already mentioned we are
very worried about the breakthroughs and
at the moment
but it is
also mentioned that we we can see that
the vaccination still is a protection
that usually the
the symptoms are less severe after the
vaccination especially after complete
vaccination
and that in the ic units the patients
who had the full vaccinations um still
are not the overwhelming number
so this is what we have to point out
at the medical side and politically that
we still need to increase the number of
patients of people who are fully
vaccinated right now in germany these
are two-thirds of the population so
67 but this is not enough to really get
the protection
and as it was also mentioned
we are currently
thinking about giving the recommendation
for people who are vaccinated after
several months to get a booster
vaccination yeah so as it was mentioned
in the example so the doctor we heard
had the vaccination seven months ago and
so currently we are discussing whether
this should be should be a general
recommendation for people after six
months to get the boosted vaccination
and yet just on the boosters um we have
15 million germans over 70 who are
eligible for booster shots
and uh many german states are only just
starting to administer them our
authorities are moving too slowly again
what we can see is that we are
struggling into the fourth wave and we
have to
do
as fast as possible what we can do
and the recommendation is already out so
what we need now is that people get
aware of the situation and that people
go and see their doctors when they have
the recommendation for the booster
vaccination
germany's the german parliament will
decide in three weeks whether to end the
state of emergency what would you like
to see happen
um the
declaration of the general state of
emergency
which was planned to
hold place in the end of november
just would mean the end to the general
state of the pandemic situation
this means not however that the pandemic
situation is over in germany
this would be the wrong impression
what we can see however is that um the
incidence differs in germany so we're
just going to interrupt you there just
we have with 30 seconds to go what would
you like to see parliament decide
i would like to
see parliament decide that
also when we declare the general
pandemic state to be over that there
still is room for the german federal
states to have some room for decisions
um for
requirements that are still to be made
especially the testing has to go on
especially when we see that it doesn't
prevent you from getting the virus and
from spreading the virus that you get
the vaccination so this is what we have
to do
besides from declaring the general
pandemic situation to be over okay thank
you for that dr tina rudolph stp member
s
deep spd member of the bundestag thank
you
thank you so much
let's take a round off of some more
headlines from the pandemic israel has
opened its borders to fully vaccinated
to visitors for the first time in 20
months in an attempt to boost the
country's struggling tourism industry in
the us white house press secretary jen
sackey says she's contracted covet and
she's not part of president biden's
delegation to the cop 26 summit this
week and the european commission has
suspended its funding of the world
health organization's covet 19 programme
in the democratic republic of congo this
over the u.n agency's handling of a sex
abuse scandal